Morgen Linus.
Morgen Linus. Guten Morgen Tim.
Bereitest du auch den Ausstieg aus der Intelligenzgemeinschaft vor?
Manchmal habe ich den Eindruck, ja.
Mit Schwung in die neue Woche. Äh Politik ist wieder da mit der einhundertvierundfünfzigsten Iteration. Version. Soll man das überhaupt nennen?
Ist irgendwie eine komische Zahl, hundertvierundfünfzig. Ja, ne, fällt mir nicht.
Pfütze. Wieso? Ähm das war halt auf lustigere Zahlen hinweisen.
Ja, müssen wir mehr Sendungen machen.
Machen wir denn das nächste Mal ein Special?
Ja, müssen wir auch mal machen.
Bietet sich jetzt von der Zahl her nicht viel mehr an als ähm zweihundert oder so, also da ist ja jetzt noch nicht mal ein Hexe dezimalen äh Umfeld viel zu finden. Hundertzweiundneunzig vielleicht noch.
Ja. Ach, weiß ich nicht, ne. Entscheiden wir später.
Entscheiden wir dann später. Genau, weil wir haben genug zu tun mit äh Feedback zu äh unseren Sendungen. Das zu empfangen, zu lesen, zu interpretieren.
Zu interpretieren vor allem.
Ja, aber man kaut sich ja da so äh durch.
Also ich habe äh wir haben letzte Woche ja gesprochen über das WLAN-Gesetz, welches jetzt die wenn ich das recht entsinne Paragraphen acht und zehn des Telemediengesetzes ähm ändern.
Also weniger ein neues Gesetz, sondern vielmehr eine Gesetzesinitiative, die bestehende Gesetze ändert, ergänzt.
Aber so ist das gefühlt bei dem größeren Teil der Gesetze, der größere Teil der Gesetze äh ist eigentlich immer Diffs auf bestehende.
Aber konkret betroffen sind Medien.
Nur Telemediengesetz. Paragraphen acht und zehn.
Okay, Telemedien.
Ähm und zwar hatten wir da, haben wir uns äh letzte Woche etwas länger mit dem Begriff geschäftsmäßig auseinandergesetzt und da äh gab's dann auch mehrere Kommentare zu. Ähm woraufhin ich mich äh direkt mal wieder an Ulf Buhrmeier gewandt habe, der sich mit dem Thema
offenes WLAN-Jahr äh und vor allem mit diesem Gesetz ja durchaus beschäftigt. Hier hat ja letzte Woche sogar erwähnt, dass er da den Vortrag
beim Camp zugehalten hat und bei der beim elften Geburtstag von und ich musste mir also Rat von ihm einholen und erklärte mir geschäftsmäßig bedeutet nur
ernsthaft und auf Dauer angelegt. Also nicht unbedingt mit der Absicht zur Gewinnerzielung.
Genau, wir haben auch, muss man dazu sagen, nicht nur sind wir äh auf diese Bedeutung nicht eingegangen, sondern wir haben's dann auch noch mit gewerblich
immer wieder äh verwechselten Durcheinander gebracht. Das äh ist natürlich ein Fehler, den bereuen wir und äh tun hiermit auch Buße, ja, ist ja nicht immer ganz so einfach in dieser äh juristischen Welt,
Also das sei jetzt hier einfach nochmal deutlich unterschieden.
Genau, der Problempunkt bei diesem Gesetz nach Ulf-Interpretation ähm liegt nämlich weniger darin, ob das jetzt geschäftsmäßig ist oder nicht, sondern er sagt,
Der Gesetzentwurf geht grundsätzlich davon aus, dass es berechtigte und unberechtigte Nutzer gäbe.
Also sowohl als auch.
Sowohl als auch, ja?
Und zwar sagt äh sagt, dass sieht das Gesetz ja nun vor. Ein Provider, also ein,
Zugangs, ein Internetzugangsanbieter,
haftet grundsätzlich gar nicht. Ein WLAN-Betreiber haftet nur dann nicht,
wenn Maßnahmen ergriffen wurden. Und diese zumutbaren Maßnahmen, da werden zwei genannt. Erstens,
Ähm,
Der Nutzer und der die Nutzer müssen eine Erklärung abgeben, keine Rechtsverletzung zu begehen. Ähm das ist das, was man auch heute hat. Äh wir bei kommerziellen,
WLAN-Anbietern ich halte mich hier an die allgemeinen Geschäftsbedingungen, Klick äh Checkbox weiter geht's, ne? Wenn man die Checkbox nicht setzt, dann darf man da nicht rein. Ähm.
Ist natürlich eine eine Maßnahme, deren Wirksamkeit, denke ich mal, völlig,
völlig also völlig außer Frage steht es, totaler Unsinn. Das wird jetzt niemanden davon abhalten, eine Rechtsverletzung zu begehen. Ähm,
Oder ne, also so, oh, jetzt wollte ich hier falsch hin, aber da steht, das darf ich gar nicht. Dann mache ich das mal nicht.
Ja und vor allem das das sollte auch der sein. Also ich meine, man nimmt ja sowieso erstmal von jedem Bürger an, dass er keine Rechtsverletzung begeht, weil ist ja verboten.
Genau, also das ja, das genau, man könnte genauso könnte ich das jetzt überall, ne. Du darf äh in meine Kneipe nur rein,
wenn du wenn du zustimmst, hier keine äh Rechtsverletzung zu begehen. Wenn so, also totaler Unsinn, ähm aber wird eben verlangt und wir waren ja immer bei dem wichtigen Beispiel Freifunk. Das kann, könnte,
Wenn es denn verlangt wäre, Freifunk auch leisten. Nervt aber geht,
ist unsinnig, bringt nichts, aber wenn es äh das Gesetz nun mal so will, dann könnte man ähm das durchaus bauen, ja, so eine äh so eine.
Porto Lösung.
Ja?
Aber eigentlich nicht will.
Will man nicht. Das ist auch das, was dann immer zu allen möglichen Problemen führt, wenn äh irgendwie
wenn man dann irgendwelche Seiten neu lädt und dann auf HTTPS geht's dann nicht oder es wird bemängelt, dass das Zertifikat kaputt ist, weil ja da dieser dieses dran geht, also das ist eine der großen
unschönen Dinge bei bei WLANs und bei Hotspots sind diese bisher wenig Sinn.
Ergeben diese Dinger, aber wenn es denn sein müsste, könnte man das technisch regeln. So. Das Zweite ist, dass in dem Gesetz steht.
Man müsse unberechtigten Zugriff verhindern,
und in der Begründung werden explizit zwei Beispiele genannt, nämlich erstens verschlüssele dieses WLAN.
Ja? Da wäre jetzt zum Beispiel dieses Beispiel ähm du bist in so einem Café, ne? Also du hast einen betreibst einen Kaffee, hast ein WLAN-Hotspot drin, was dich dann häufig sehe, ist, dass der Hotspot tatsächlich einen Key hat, ne und.
Wenn dann wieder alle Nachbarn in dem WLAN drin hängen, dann wird der Klima geändert, ne? Und wenn du dann
wenn du jetzt denn dann in dieses Cafe gehst als Gast und deinen deinen Kaffee bestellt hast, dann kannst du nach dem Kiefern und dann wird der dir genannt und dann kannst du das WLAN mitbenutzen. Verschlüsselung des WLANs heißt, nur,
jemand, der diesen Schlüssel hat, kann diesem WLAN äh beitreten
Also kann dann IP äh mit der mit dem Router sprechen, kann sich über DAZP eine Adresse geben lassen und ansonsten ist ist dieses WLAN einfach,
Kryptisch für diese Person, ne? Also es wird der der Zugang verhindert und es wird außerdem dann noch verhindert, dass äh dass du zumindest ohne den Schlüssel zu haben äh mitschnorcheln kannst, ja?
Ähm auch das natürlich eine Maßnahme, die absolut unsinnig ist, wenn es darum geht,
Zu verhindern, dass Menschen Rechtsverletzungen begehen,
Ja, also äh das verschlüsselte WLAN verhindert ja jetzt nicht, dass jemand, der reingelassen wurde, dann eine rechte Verletzung begeht, ne. Aber es ist für die eben wichtig, dadurch gibt es.
Berechtigte Nutzer und unberechtigte Nutzer und den Zugang der unberechtigten.
Verhindert man durch diese durch diese Verschlüsselung.
Also anstatt die bekannten Nachbarn reinzulassen, ist man nur die unbekannten Kaffeegäste rein und dadurch ist.
Genau. Ähm und natürlich ist das auch äh,
steht das im im Gegensatz zu dem Ziel des Gesetzes, weil in der äh Begründung des Gesetzes heißt es ja, wir wollen die Verbreitung von Wählern bestärken
äh äh ähm beschleunigen, wir wollen das mehr, dass es mehr WLAN gibt und das,
Natürlich nicht dadurch hin, dass du sagst, ähm dann macht macht die Dinger dicht. So, wir wollen mehr WLAN, macht die dicht. Ähm,
ein anderes Beispiel, was sie nennen, ist äh eine Nutzerregistrierung.
Ja, also du musst den Nutzer registrieren und dann äh hast du auch äh unberechtigten Zugriff verhindert. Das sind die beiden Beispiele, die dort genannt werden.
Und jetzt der Kernpunkt, den den Ulf hier kritisiert oder den den Ulf hier sieht, den ich auch nachvollziehen kann. Er sagt,
Im Gesetz steht explizit, du musst unberechtigten Zugriff verhindern. Und das, daraus könnte man jetzt zwei Interpretationen herleiten. Erstens,
Bei Freifunk gibt es keine unberechtigten, also müssen die auch nichts tun, um das zu äh müssen die keine Sicherungsmaßnahmen ergreifen, um deren Zugriff zu zu verhindern.
Wäre alles gut.
Dann wäre alles gut oder,
Die alternative Interpretation, es muss unberechtigte geben, damit du überhaupt das Haftungsrivileg bekommen kannst.
Also irgendeiner muss draußen bleiben.
Irgendeiner, irgendeiner muss unberechtigt sein und den musst du effektiv daran hindern. Ähm und wenn du das mit zu einer zumutbaren Maßnahme daran hindern und wenn das für dich nicht zutrifft, dann bist du eben auch hast du auch nicht das Haftungsprivileg. Das ist die andere, mögliche juristische Interpretation des Textes. Und äh sagt also, sobald du in einem Gesetz,
Das Risiko einer derartigen Fehlinterpretation hast, kannst du auch davon ausgehen, dass irgendein äh Amtsrichter äh diese,
andere Interpretationen ähm.
Einfach gelten lässt.
Einfach mal anwenden wird. Das heißt, dann sind frei und offene Netze genau nicht haftungsbefreit und dann ist das ein Problem. Das ist also das, wovor ähm.
Ulf hier nochmal explizit warnt, was ich in der letzten Sendung nicht vernünftig ausgearbeitet habe, obwohl ich seinen Vortrag dazu äh zweimal gehört habe. Ähm,
Deswegen auch mein mein Ausstieg jetzt aus der Intelligenz-Community. So jetzt stellt sich die Frage,
Da hatten wir ähm in der letzten Woche ja auch ein bisschen Verwirrung. Auf deiner Seite, auf meiner, glaube ich, nicht, aber vermutlich habe ich sie trotzdem auf unterschiedlichen Seiten gestiftet, wenn ich dich verwirrt habe. Ähm was ist jetzt also ein Dienstanbieter und was ein
ein Zugangsanbieter, weil was mache ich denn zum Beispiel, wenn ich ein offenes WLAN trotzdem anbieten möchte? Also ich als äh Linus Neumann
Sitze zu Hause, sage, ich möchte hier ein offenes WLAN machen. Also nehme ich ein.
Hotspot oder indem ich irgendein WLAN-Gerät und sage, mach mal offenes WLAN und das äh gibt dann mal ans Internet. Und dann,
Bin ich ja genau diesem Haftungsrisiko ausgesetzt, dem ich nicht ausgesetzt werden möchte. Also unternehme ich Maßnahmen, dass äh sollte jemand eine Rechtsverletzung über mein WLAN begehen.
Zumindest nicht ich als Privatperson dafür hafte. Und da kommen also mehrere Möglichkeiten in den Sinn, ich könnte den ganzen Traffic durch Tor ruten, was etwas ist, was ich äh gerne mal mache. Ähm,
Ich könnte aber auch diesen ganzen Traffic durch ein VPN-Routen in zum Beispiel ein anderes Land,
in dem äh andere Gesetze gelten oder ich könnte äh was wir, glaube ich, auch in der letzten Woche angesprochen haben, mich
in das Freifunk VPN anschließen, welches äh genau zu diesem Zwecke geschaffen wurde, dass eben wenn IP-Adressen Halterfeststellungen gemacht werden, man sofort sieht, A, das ist Freifunk und da endet dann das
endet dann die weitere Ermittlung des Nutzers, weil man weiß, A das sind die, die sind sowohl als Dienste, als auch als Zugangsanbieter ähm,
registriert in Deutschland und genießen daher das Haftungsprivileg, ja? Unterschiedliche äh Möglichkeiten, äh die es hier gibt, aber dass die einzig wirklich,
wahre im Moment scheint zu sein, irgendwie ähm,
den Traffic zu maskieren, damit's gar nicht mehr bis zu einem nach Hause kommt. Weil was wir nicht haben, ist äh oder was wir zumindest gesetzlich im Moment nicht haben.
In der Rechtsprechung hatten wir jetzt gerade den Umschwung gesehen, ne? Stichwort negative Feststellungsklage und so, das habe ich ja in der letzten Sendung kurz angemerkt.
Ich stehe auf sehr wackelnden Füßen, wenn ich diesen Traffic einfach unter der Linus Neumann äh Berlin IP ins Internet gebe. So, da,
Kann das durchaus passieren, dass ich dann dass ich Post bekomme und mich dann in einem in irgendeinem juristischen Akt wiederfinde, das möchte ich ja nicht.
So jetzt äh also drei Lösungen ähm frei vom VPN Tor oder irgendwie ein äh,
ein VPN und da habe ich letzte Woche, glaube ich, auch genannt, ähm iPreda ist da eine Wahl, die ich persönlich äh getroffen habe, bei denen ich glücklich bin. Warum möchtest du mich jetzt unterbrechen?
Weil ich auch gerne noch,
klarstellen äh wollte, was wir sozusagen durcheinander gebracht haben. Also es war ja explizit zwar auch der Sendungstitel,
die Rede von diesen Gefahr geneigten Diensten. Und was mich äh in unserer Diskussion äh auch im Nachgang noch ein bisschen verwirrt hat sozusagen,
Auf der einen Seite gibt es eben jetzt diese Definition. Es gibt da böse Diensteanbieter und auf der anderen Seite gibt's eben die Fragestellung
Provider, so und äh was wir, glaube ich, ein bisschen zusammengeworfen haben, ist ähm wie das jetzt im Zusammenhang äh steht. Und steht halt erstmal überhaupt nicht unbedingt im Zusammenhang, sondern es gibt das eine und es gibt das andere und es wird halt in dem Moment auch schwierig für die Provider
wenn sie eben Gefahr geneigte Dienste verwenden und da kam dann ein Beispiel äh ins Rollen.
Um das äh Beispiel zu hier kurz auszufinden,
Provider ist derjenige, der mich mit dem Internet in Verbindung setzt und alles, was danach passieren kann oder könnte es ein Diensttee-Anbieter. Und ähm in der letzten Woche war ich auf der Suche nach einem,
Diensteanbieter, denen man Gefahr geneigt nennen könnte,
der in diesem Fall dann unter die Räder käme. Und da wollte ich äh ungerne das Beispiel mega verwenden, weil ich mega ja nicht gut finde. Ähm,
und habe deshalb den von mir geschätzten Dienst I-Preda äh genannt, der eben einen VPN äh Dienst anbietet, wo man
eine IP-Adresse äh in Schäden bekommt und dadurch unter einer anderen äh Juristikion mit diesem Dienst ist. Und,
ähm.
Mega gibt's ja auch gar nicht mehr.
Geht's dir nicht mehr?
Ist ja alles konfisziert worden, die Domains et cetera und die sind.
Längst wieder dieses Megapunkt co Punkt NZ äh seit Jahren wieder am Lauf.
Ach so, aber nicht unter oder unter äh kommen auf jeden Fall nicht. Wurst.
Mega Punkt coms.
Amiga CONZ in der Tat gibt's noch. Du hast Recht. Mhm.
Siehst du? So ähm aber nicht ablenken, so.
Das Beispiel war deshalb ungünstig oder falsch, weil sie nämlich eine,
Ein Firmensitz in Zypern haben äh und eine ein Prepaid-Dienst in Schweden anbieten. Und deshalb natürlich per se sowieso nicht von diesem deutschen Gesetz betroffen wären.
Ja? Ähm wie gesagt, mir ging's dabei darum, ein Beispiel zu finden, was denn zum Beispiel ein Diensteanbieter wäre, der bei,
mit einer guten Motivation und einer guten notwendigen Dienstleistung,
hier unter die Räder kommen könnte. Und da damit ich jetzt nicht den nächsten Dienst äh äh irgendwie und in der falschen Justicion schildere, nehme ich jetzt mal als Beispiel
den äh Linus Neumann Mediathek VPN äh an Dienst, ähm der euch sagt, wenn ihr auf,
Fernreisen seid in in das europäische Ausland oder in in das asiatische Ausland und mit der,
IP, die euch, die euer Hotel Hotspot da habt, hat nicht auf die ARD-Mediathek zugreifen könnt.
Dann könnt ihr meinen VPN-Dienst nutzen, ähm der euch dann mit einer deutschen IP darauf zugreifen lässt. Und.
Würde ich jetzt als das als Linus Neumann äh Deutschland anbieten und gleichzeitig sagen, ich bin ja äh
Datensparsam, äh solange meine Rechnung stimmt, äh solange ihr bezahlt für diesen VPN Dienst, könnt ihr den nutzen.
Dann könnte ich sehr schnell unter die Räder kommen als ein Gefahr geneigter Dienst, weil ich in Deutschland einen VPN-Dienst betreiben würde, der euch dazu hilft, Anonymität anonym euch im Internet zu bewegen,
und ich gleichzeitig äh eventuell eben äh.
In der Lage wäre, euch an die äh Behörden zu verraten. Genau deshalb ist Predator eben auch äh im mit seinem juristischen Konstrukt äh ein ein Prepaid-Dienst in Schweden.
Ähm der nämlich, also man bezahlt da im Voraus und äh nutzt das nutzt dann also bezahlt was weiß ich, für ein oder drei oder sechs neun, zwölf Monate. Ähm,
und nutzt dann den Dienst, den man schon bezahlt hat. Nein und das heißt für die, dass sie.
Ein Minimum an Daten nur erfassen müssen, weil sie keinen Grund haben mehr zu erfassen, weil sie ja der Dienst ja im voraus bezahlt ist,
und sie unterliegen außerdem.
Ähm der der Juristik Schwedens bei dem Herausrücken von Daten, die nochmal besonders ähm streng ist, nämlich sie müssen,
müssten die Daten, die der Nutzer angegeben hat, bei der Registrierung nur im Rahmen eines eines Ermittlungsverfahren wegen einer Straftat rausgeben, nicht bei einer Ordnungswidrigkeit,
So und das heißt, die der Dienst ist quasi dadurch besonders ähm,
gegen juristische äh Zugriffe gewappnet, weil sie einerseits eine hohe Hürde haben, überhaupt Daten rausgeben zu müssen und andererseits die geringsten Anforderungen haben überhaupt Daten von ihren Nutzern aufzunehmen.
Insgesamt, glaube ich, äh ist sehr lange her, dass ich mich da äh registriert habe. Ich bin da schon sehr lange Kunde. Aber ich glaube, ich brauchte nur eine E-Mail-Adresse.
Und die E-Mail-Adresse gibt's ja überall, ja? Keine. Aber bevor ich da jetzt aufhebe, was falsches sage, könnt ihr ja mal ausprobieren, euch da zu registrieren. Die haben, glaube ich, äh so ein Angebot
drei Tage kostenlos oder so einfach mal ausprobieren. Und das ist zum Beispiel sehr zu empfehlen, wenn man jetzt ein freies WLAN anbieten möchte einfach mal spontan, dann wirft man das eben da rein ähm und ist alle Sorgen los.
Und genau deshalb findet sich auch so meine Theorie äh dieser Passus in ähm,
in diesem als WLAN-Gesetz bekannt gewordenen Gesetz, dass man nämlich sagt, okay, da müssen wir die die äh Anonymisierungsdienste, den müssen wir auch noch zu Leibe rücken. Gleichzeitig.
Glaube ich aber, dass es im Prinzip kaum jemand in Deutschland ernsthaft einen Gefahr geneigten Dienst anbietet,
Das äh also nach der Definition, die wir in der letzten Sendung heruntergebetet haben, weil ähm.
In Deutschland ja sowieso kaum irgendwas angeboten wird. Ich meine, wenn du
in Deutschland eine Webseite betreibst, äh stehst du ja schon mit einem, mit einem Fuß im Knast. Äh jetzt fang mal an und mach irgendwie als deutsche GmbH einen Anonymisierungsdienst. Gibt es auch
ja? Äh aber diese Dienste haben alle ähm sind alle darauf angewiesen spezifische äh juristische Konstrukte auf ihr Dienstangebot anzuwenden.
Um Daten eben nicht rausgeben zu müssen. Und ähm kann man da auf jeden Fall äh sehr zugute halten, dass sie das genau ihr juristisches Konstrukt dort erklären und aus sagen, wir geben,
Folgende Daten raus. Ja, da weißt du schon vorher, ähm dass du dich da vielleicht nicht mit deiner äh
Haupt-E-Mail-Adresse registrieren solltest, ja? Oder du weißt auch vorher, wenn du sagst, okay, irgendwas, weshalb Strafermittlung gegen mich äh angestrengt werden sollten,
Mache ich einfach nicht. Also kann ich darauf vertrauen, dass es keine Bedingungen in meinem Leben äh in in der von mir geplanten Internetnutzung gibt, äh die äh da mich einer Gefahr aussetzen würde.
Also das nochmal zur äh zur Definition Gefahr geneigter Dienste und ähm.
Nochmal, um nochmal sicher und richtig zu stellen, zu betonen, dass ich mit da ein Beispiel gesucht habe und zwar eines von einem Dienstanbieter, der ähm sehr viele äh,
gute ähm Initiativen unterstützt und für für viele gute Dinge,
gut ist. Im Gegensatz zu äh mega.
So, aber bevor jetzt die Meganutzer denken, dass dass ihnen das Megabid verboten wird, nein, äh Mega hat auch sicherlich den Sitz nicht in Deutschland.
Ja? Äh im Prinzip.
Jetzt Neuseeland so die bessere Wahl ist, wird sich noch zeigen.
Im Prinzip heißt, zeigt's nur, dass es äh offenbar mal wieder dieses Gesetz für egal was du machst, ob du den Leuten Internet gibst oder
oder irgendwelche Diensteleistungen, die unkompliziert funktionieren, dass Deutschland einfach der falsche Standort dafür ist. Und das ist natürlich nicht nur,
für uns persönlich schlecht, weil wir dann.
Juristische Konstrukte bauen müssen oder weil wir auf Dienstlein Dienstanbieter aus dem Ausland angewiesen sind, ähm sondern.
Weil es auch diesen den Standort Deutschland, ja, äh für die nächsten Jahrzehnte in in große Gefahr begibt, wenn wir ähm
eine Kultur äh haben, die die alles, was irgendwie mit freiem Zugang und
und Beschleunigung der Innovation zu tun hat mit solchen Hürden belegen. Insofern kann man da auch äh ohne ein äh libertärer Fanatiker zu sein, sehr stark äh gegen dieses Gesetz,
oponieren.
Ich denke, das ist auch nichts Neues. Ich meine, diese Kultur der Angst äh existiert eigentlich schon seit langem. Ähm.
Allem, was eigentlich so das Netz betrifft. Ja, also da ist einfach die Balance in der Abwägung zwischen Chancen und Risiken schon immer in die falsche Richtung äh gekippt,
sehr viel mehr ausgeglichen werden, um das mal wieder eine Balance zu bekommen.
Ja und wenn du dir anschaust
ähm ich meine, man kann natürlich einerseits sagen, ja äh ist jetzt irgendwie, also er hat offenbar die beste Lösung, die in Europa möglich ist, gefunden
ja? Aber überleg mal, was die da fürn, was was die auf sich nehmen muss, ja? Äh an an juristischen Konstrukten und wie schwierig das war, einfach mal einen Dienst anzubieten,
der Internetzugang anbietet, ne?
Und äh nochmal die Wahl, äh wer die die Entscheidung, ob man jetzt äh den Traffic äh durch Tor oder durch durch einen vielleicht sogar kommerziellen IP äh ähm äh Open,
Entschuldigung. Durch durch Tor oder einen kommerziellen VPN Anbieter äh ruten möchte, ähm ist hauptsächlich eine Entscheidung,
Darüber, welche Geschwindigkeit man da äh erwartet, ne, also irgendwie.
Ein Hotspot für ein Cafe durch Tor zu pumpen, wird ähm im Zweifelsfall
relativ äh frustrierend sein und ist außerdem natürlich auch eine Frage des Vertrauens, gerade bei Tor hat man immer mal wieder Ärger mit äh mit Exit-Notes, die versuchen äh den Traffic zu manipulieren. Das heißt, da,
ähm,
Das ist kein großes Problem, aber eines, mit dem man früher oder später mal konfrontiert wird, wenn man sein äh sein Tor Entry nicht so konfiguriert, dass er
bestimmte Exits nur nutzt und so. Und da kann man sich natürlich einfach mit mit 'n VPN-Anbieter, der für 'ne kleine Mark sagt, hier uns kannst du vertrauen
Wir pumpen das ordentlich raus für dich und wir wir geben dir eine vernünftige Leistung. Äh kann man da durchaus mal auch diese Wahl treffen.
Wir blättern nach vorne und äh schauen uns mal die ähm neuesten,
Aktivitäten aus dem Bereich europäische Union an. Hier geht's um den Fall,
ähm versus äh Facebook,
Wir haben da schon mehrere Male äh drüber berichtet, diese ganze Geschichte zieht sich schon ein bisschen äh länger, wo ähm wie heißt er noch, ganz äh Max Shrimps, genau,
Angefangen hat, äh Klage zu führen gegenüber Facebook, über die Ermittlung, äh über die gegen die Übermittlung von,
seinen Daten in die USA mit der Argumentation, dass das eben seine Privatsphäre et cetera,
verletzen würde, da eben in den USA die,
legale Basis nicht so ist, wie sie von Europa gefordert ist. Und das ging durch zahlreiche Instanzen. Zuletzt hatten wir darüber berichtet,
In Ausgabe Nummer hundertsiebenunddreißig,
als es die äh Entscheidung gab äh vor dem österreichischen äh Gericht, also in Wien gab's halt eine äh Entscheidung dazu, wo halt ähm.
Facebook argumentiert hat, dass äh das Wiener Gericht ja überhaupt nicht zuständig äh wäre. Jetzt ist die ganze Geschichte,
weiter eskaliert und es gab eine bemerkenswerte Vorentscheidung,
ähm beim europäischen Gerichtshof, beziehungsweise beim Generalanwalt.
Ja, also um das noch mal kurz ein bisschen aufzudröseln. Er sagt, Max Franz klagt gegen die Übermittlung seiner Facebook-Daten in die USA. Ähm,
und streitet mit der äh irischen Datenschutzbehörde unter anderem,
Ja, weil äh Facebook, äh wie die meisten Firmen sich den den Sitz in der EU danach gewählt hat, wo die geringsten Datenschutzgesetze äh gelten und das ist eben in Irland. Ähm
viel zu sehr ins Detail brauchen wir da vielleicht gar nicht zu gehen, weil das ja auch wirklich ein Fall ist äh von von Tiefe und Länge, die den Maxda äh bestreitet. Ähm,
aber das Entscheidende ist, die Basis dafür, dass die Facebook-Daten in die USA übermittelt werden. Ist das Abkommen? Das Safehar-Abkommen, da hatten wir,
Das haben wir hier, glaube ich, schon öfter äh betont äh oder erklärt, ist im Prinzip ähm,
Zum Abbau eines Handelshemmnisses geschaffen worden, wo man gesagt hat, okay, ähm,
deutscher äh Europäische Datenschutzanforderungen ähm werden in den USA erfüllt.
Punkt. Nichts anderes sagt der Safe Herber Abkommen. Und das ermöglicht den gesamten diese gesamte Datenspeicherung von äh,
oder das ermöglicht überhaupt ein Geschäftsverhältnis zwischen US-Anbietern und äh europäischen Kunden.
Weitergehen, hier gibt's nichts zu sehen.
Genau, das ist einfach hier äh das ist jetzt erfüllt. So. Ähm,
Das heißt, allgemein ist der Schutz personenbezogener Daten in den Vereinigten Staaten ausreichend oder in Übereinstimmung mit EU-Gesetzgebung. Ja, und das ist natürlich,
offenkundig nicht der Fall. Und genau deshalb brauchte man auch dieses Abkommen, damit man das juristisch äh ähm äh fest hat.
So und jetzt äh geht es um den den Fall von Max Schranz, wo der EU äh der Generalanwalt am Europäischen Gerichtshof Evebot,
ähm seine Meinung dazu kundgetan hat.
Alles bestimmt. Aber Bot ist natürlich irgendwie sehr schön.
Ja, ich sage ja immer, ich lese das immer alles nur. Ich äh muss das mit meiner,
bildungspferden Sozialisation entschuldigen.
Ähm.
Und er sagt einfach mal, dass Abkommen ähm ist ungültig.
Denn das Safehaber-Abkommen,
hindert die nationalen Behörden nicht daran, die Übermittlung der Daten europäischer Nutzer von Facebook an Server, die sich in den äh in den Vereinigten Staaten befinden, auszusetzen. Also Begründung, warum es ungültig ist,
Erstens, es gibt keinen ausreichenden Rechtsschutz für EU-Bürger in den USA, wenn dort personenbezogene Daten in großen Umfang an Firmen wie Facebook oder Google gesammelt äh werden. Ähm,
Genau dafür gab's aber natürlich dieses Abkommen. Ja, also er sagt einfach nur, das, was dieses Abkommen behauptet, ist nicht der Fall. Ja, genau, deswegen gab's das aber auch, ja. Ähm.
Ähm.
Zweitens, der Datenaustausch mit der NSA,
ist ein Eingriff in das Recht auf Achtung des Privatlebens und des Schutz und den Schutzpersonen bezogener Daten,
und äh für diesen für einen derartigen Verstoß gilt der Grundsatz der Verhältnismäßigkeit,
Das ist ja hier, der ist hier nicht gegeben, weil dieser Daten, weil diese Datenerfassung massiv und nicht zielgerichtet ist. Das heißt, da spricht, der ist nicht verhältnismäßig.
Im Prinzip auch wieder der selbe Blick wie auch auf die Vorratsdatenspeicherung als EuGH darüber befunden hat.
Und drittens sagt er, am Rande, die Entscheidung der EU-Kommission, zugunsten des sogenannten Safehar-Abkommen-Abkommens, hebt die Befugnisse nationaler,
Behörden nicht auf. Das heißt, sehr wohl kann eine äh europäische nationale Aufsichtsbehörde gegenüber,
Facebook, ähm Datenschutz für ihre Nutzer verlangen. Ähm.
Punkt. Unabhängig davon, dass, wie man jetzt immer sagt, nee, ist ja safe, aber hier ist alles in Ordnung. Hier kann sich keiner beschweren. Gehen sie bitte weiter, hier gibt's nichts zu sehen.
Ja? Das heißt, äh Safe Haber ist eben nicht,
oder darf nicht dieser Freifahrtschein sein, der einfach alle äh Rechte und Pflichten über Bord wirft und das ist er ja äh bisher gewesen, weil man immer sagt, Facebook, London, nee, SafeHav war alles in Ordnung.
Aber ist interessant, also er bezieht sich explizit auf die nationalen Aufsichtsbehörden. Das heißt, an der Stelle heißt das so viel wie.
Äh wenn die Deutschen das so und so sehen, dann gilt es erstmal so wie die Deutschen das sagen, ich meine, das würde ja so ein bisschen diesem europäischen äh Einigungsgedanken an der Stelle wieder sprechen.
Ich habe die Frage nicht verstanden.
Naja, du hast ja gesagt, äh.
Die Entscheidung, dass es so ein Safehaber-Abkommen geben soll, der EU hebt die Befugnisse nationaler Aufsichtsbehörden nicht auf. Ja. Heißt ja so viel wie die nationalen Aufsichtsbehörden, haben nach wie vor,
äh recht durchzusetzen und zwar ihr Nationales? Ich meine, welches sonst? So, das würde ja bedeuten, dass das Safehaber sozusagen komplett.
Bestandslos ist an der Stelle.
Genau das sagt er auch. Er sagt, das ist äh das ist äh ungültig, unsinnig, falsch äh lastet sein.
Jetzt muss man dazu sagen, das ist jetzt nicht das EuGH, was das beschlossen hat, sondern das ist die Aussage des Generalanwaltes,
Aber das hatten wir auch schon bei der Vorratsdatenspeicherung. Die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass sich das EuGH in eine.
Der EUGH in seiner anstehenden Entscheidung, wann auch immer die ansteht, äh seiner Auffassung anschließt, ist nicht gering,
oder sehr hoch, je nachdem wie man das so ausprobiert. Also es kann auch anders sein, nur sieht es gerade so aus, als ob Safehaber scheitert.
Ja, wollen wir mal nicht zu früh freuen, ne? Also es ist erstmal nur ein äh ein,
Äh eine Einschätzung des Generalanwaltes. Jetzt könnte der EuGH immer noch sagen, nö, dem dem diese Einschätzung schließen wir uns nicht an, aber äh es sieht gerade mal sehr äh,
sehr gut aus, ja. Da wird das werden wir natürlich dann jetzt sehen, wie dann da das Urteil gesprochen wird. Ähm.
Aber das das sieht schon mal, das sieht schon mal spannend aus. Ich meine, andererseits, ich meine, irgendeiner muss es ja mal sagen.
Jeder weiß halt, äh ich meine, das das Safe Harber irgendwie ein Witz ist, das weiß irgendwie wissen alle, seit Jahrzehnten.
So oder nicht jetzt seit Jahrzehnten. Ich glaube, das ist jetzt ungefähr äh etwas über ein Jahrzehnt alt, dieses Abkommen in seiner aktuellen Fassung. Ich weiß gar nicht genau, äh.
Wie alt dieses wann das genau geschlossen wurde.
Ich weiß, dass wir beim vorletzten Camp schon drüber gesprochen haben.
Gibt da so verschiedene, die sie so heißen.
So, damit der Datenverkehr zwischen EU und USA nicht zum Erliegen kommt, wurde zwischen neunzehnhundertacht und neunzehn und zweitausend ein besonderes Verfahren entwickelt. Ähm.
Entscheidung hatte die EU im Juli zweitausend anerkannt, dass bei den Unternehmen, die diesen System beigetreten sind, ein ausreichender Schutz für die Personen bedatene, bezogenen Daten von EU-Bürgern bestehe, also seit
fünfzehn Jahren leiden wir jetzt inzwischen unter diesem unter diesem Abkommen.
Ja, vielleicht nicht mehr so lang.
So, dann mache ich hier noch einen Link.
Dann springen wir wieder zurück auf die deutsche Ebene und zwar genauer nach Berlin, wo es wieder weiterging mit dem Untersuchungsausschuss, gegen,
Unter anderem die NSA, immer noch Namensgeber, primärer Namensgeber, zumindest im umgangssprachlichen äh Sinne, aber wo.
Allerlei Geheimdienstaktivitäten regelmäßig wieder ans Netz äh ans Licht kommen, auch ans Netz, dank dank vor allem der äh Liveblogging-Aktivitäten von Netzpolitik ORG,
Worum ging's denn diesmal?
Äh diesmal war äh KM da, äh ein Sachbearbeiter in der BND-Zentrale in Pullach. Ähm.
Dessen Aufgabe es über viele Jahre war und diese Lektoren, die von der NSA geliefert wurden, zu prüfen.
Ähm seit zweitausendacht sollte er untersuchen, ob die Suchbegriffe gegen deutsches,
Rechts verstoßen. Und wenn er solche Suchbegriffe gefunden hat, dann hat er die an die BND-Außenstelle in Bad Aibling zurückgesendet,
ja? Das war also seine Aufgabe. Und jetzt äh,
Muss man sagen, KM hat wahrscheinlich das Memo nicht bekommen. Denn äh die offizielle Sprachregelung zu diesen Selektoren ist ja erstens.
Diese diese Selektoren sind streng geheim. Ähm und die Opposition klagt gerade auf deren Herausgabe,
Außerdem ähm hat.
Der äh Bundestagsuntersuchungsausschuss mit seiner Einsetzung ein Löschmoratorium ausgesprochen.
Um zu verhindern, dass Beweise vernichtet werden.
Und hat gesagt, okay, beim BND wird werden jetzt wird erstmal nix, was irgendwie relevant für unseren Untersuchungs äh Gegenstand ist, mehr gelöscht.
Und.
Hat jetzt also im NSA Untersuchungsausschuss bekanntgegeben, dass also viele E-Mails mit sogenannten NSA Selektoren vom BND.
Versehentlich gelöscht wurden. Der FAN versehen, ne, ich meine klar, das.
Das war jetzt keine Absicht. Nee, das kann nicht immer mal passieren. Ah.
Nee, das kann immer mal passieren, ne, dass du gerade, wenn jetzt gegen dich ermittelt wird, aus Versehen mal ähm.
Kaffeetasse Umfeld.
Beweise versehentlich löscht, die gegen dich jetzt, die dich belastet hätten, ne. Das kann ja, das kommt in den besten Familien vor.
Also den besten Geheimdiensten.
Geheimdiensten vor und äh,
Ja, so, jetzt muss man sich überlegen, welche was hat der da jetzt grade äh vernichtet, ne?
Diese Listen der NSA Selektoren sind bekanntermaßen,
Die wichtigsten Beweise in diesem Untersuchungsausschuss, denn Sie äh zeigen
ob und wie der BND der NSA geholfen hat, äh in Deutschland was Illegales zu tun. Und wie der BND damit gegen deutsche Interessen verstoßen hat. Und wenn.
Der BND. Diese Beweise versehentlich gelöscht hat,
dann kann das ja nur ein ein bedauerliches äh Versehen gewesen sein. Ja, also das ist ein, ein, ein, ein Skandal äh da fehlt mir schon.
Da fehlt mir schon irgendwie der Vergleich jetzt, ne. Ähm noch dazu interessant.
Äh sagt er, dass diese die Nachrichten, in denen ähm also die E-Mail-Nachrichten mit den Selektoren ähm.
Mit den aussortierten Selektoren, ja? Also die Selektoren, die ähm wo er sagt, okay, die sind zu bemängeln, ja? Und dann irgendwie nach Bad Aidingen zurückgemailt hat.
Die wurden mit der geringsten Geheimhaltung versendet. Und das ist spannend, weil ähm.
Die Abgeordneten, ja, insbesondere mit der Begründung von diesen Selektoren ferngehalten werden, da diese streng geheim werden.
Also man sagt, es tut uns leid, der Untersuchungsausschuss hat zwar einen Untersuchungsauftrag der Untersuchungsausschuss äh muss zwar lückenlos aufklären.
Aber diese Sachen sind so geheim, dass wir noch nicht mal eine Untersuchungsausschuss da dranlassen können, sondern nur ein Sonderermittler.
Herr Graulich, der im Kellersitz und die Ausdrucke blättert. Ja.
Graulich, der da sitzt und die gelöscht niemals liest. So und äh äh jetzt stellt sich raus, dass die intern irgendwie auf der geringsten Geheimhaltungsstufe äh durch den ganzen Laden gemäht wurden.
Also sozusagen nur für den Dienstgebrauch oder was ist das dann? Irgendwie so. Auf jeden Fall nicht streng geheim.
Ich glaube, das haben wir hier schon öfter mal erklärt. Ich kenne mich da äh aber ich glaube, NFD ist die niedrigste, ne?
Glaube auch. Das glauben wir. Korrigiert uns, korrigiert, aber wir glauben, was wir glauben.
Ist wahrscheinlich das glauben wir mein Glaube ist mir ich bin frei in meinem Glauben.
Ist auch unerschütterlich unser Glaube.
Aber auf jeden Fall nicht streng geheim, ja? Und das wäre natürlich jetzt auch nochmal eine eine Frechheit in sich, dass man.
Behauptet hat, irgendwas wäre total geheim, obwohl es das gar nicht war. Da hat sich der ein bisschen verplappert oder was?
Ich glaube, wie gesagt, der hat das Memo nicht bekommen oder der hat einfach mal sehr wohl das Memo bekommen und sich gesagt, Arsch lecken. Und das könnte ich mir auch gut vorstellen, wenn er seit zweitausendacht damit beschäftigt war, irgendwie diese Selektoren zu filtern, äh
und das irgendwie, wir haben ja das Ausmaß dieser Menge an Selektoren äh durchaus schon gesehen. Äh und ähm.
Dieser KM hat er ja sicherlich äh eine Art äh äh Sisyphas Arbeit verrichtet, ne. Ähm
und wahrscheinlich äh vielleicht ist er auch einfach äh gefrustet und hat gesagt
ey, jetzt habe ich die Schnauze voll. Ich habe das jetzt sieben Jahre lang gemacht. Das ist lächerlich, ich bin froh, äh endlich mal mein äh Gewissen da erleichtern zu können äh in diesem Untersuchungsausschuss. Da ich nicht da war, kann ich da jetzt nicht die die Einschätzung zu geben, äh.
Wie da jetzt so die die Stimmung äh um diese Person war.
Ähm aber der Hammer noch zu diesem gelöschten E-Mails ist, äh die entsprechende Abteilung, die die äh E-Mails gelöscht hat, hat darüber auch offenbar niemand informiert, ja? Ähm hat also seinen Vorgesetzten Nichtmeldung erstattet
und äh dann wurde die Sitzung unterbrochen.
Ähm weil der Anwalt von KM sagte, äh er würde jetzt keine weiteren Aussagen machen, weil das Risiko besteht, dass äh äh seine Aussagen Gegenstand von disziplinarischen Ermittlungen würden.
Vermutlich gegen ihn oder gegen andere, aber ich meine, ist auch geil.
Sorry jetzt.
Ich meine, disziplinarische Ermittlungen, so sind das Mindeste, was wir von diesem NSA-Untersuchungsausschuss haben,
Also disziplinarische Ermittlungen, so, wenn das Risiko besteht, ja, ich denke auch mit der gleichen Begründung, haben sie diese Selektoren gelöscht, weil sie auch gesagt haben, oh ja, da besteht durchaus das Risiko disziplinarischer
Ermittlungen, das löschen wir mal wieder.
Da können wir uns jetzt nicht zu äußern, weil das könnte unter Umständen zur Aufklärung.
Beitragen. Ja.
Beitragen, ja? Das ist geil, ja? Da sieht man mal, ne? Und äh Aufklärung ist ja sozusagen auch so ein Wort, was Sie sicherlich auf Ihre Fahnen schreiben, ja? Das ist ja für Aufklärung eigentlich zuständig werden, aber das ist wirklich das Letzte, worum Sie sich kümmern.
Aber der Hammer ist, die Sitzung wurde unterbrochen und Bundesregierung und BND sollen jetzt also Zeit bekommen, festzustellen, was genau verschwunden ist und wie.
Was witzig ist, weil offenkundig wissen die ja, was verschwunden ist und wie. Der KM hat's ja erzählt, wurde gelöscht aus Versehen.
Aber so alles, was euch interessiert, huch, da kommt ja, kommt bei den Geheimdiensten ja ganz selten vor.
Und äh dass die mal aus Versehen irgendwie Beweise gegen sich selber löschen so, ne? Das ist nicht weg. Zuletzt irgendwie äh in Thüringen passiert vor einem Jahr oder so. Aber ist jetzt nicht regelmäßig, dass sowas.
Das passiert auch immer nur, wenn jemand darauf Zugriff haben.
Ja ja genau, nee, sonst nicht. Ähm ja, also da wurde die die Sitzung jetzt unterbrochen,
Und dann hat er, äh, was ich auch sehr schön fand, äh, noch, ähm, dazu ausgesagt.
Wie es denn um die ominösen Filter bestellt ist, die wir schützen sollen. Wir wissen ja, äh der BND als Auslandsgeheimdienst darf
Laut seinem Arbeitsauftrag diese ganze Massenüberwachung machen, aber er darf keine keine deutschen Verkehre erfassen, ne? Und das war ja schon irgendwie immer das ähm.
Also das ist ja auch bei der NSA das Problem, ne, wo die Amerikaner sagen, ja NSA ist schön und gut, aber bitte nicht gegen uns
Ja, was wie ist das mit der Wahrscheinlichkeit, äh dass dass ich dadrin erfasst werde. Und das gilt natürlich bei für den BND auch und der BND darf eben keine deutschen.
Verkehre erfassen und dazu setzen sie Filter ein. Über diese Filter wurde in der Vergangenheit immer sehr wenig gesprochen.
Von Seiten des BND und es gab da irgendwie sowas wie ja, wenn das eine DE Domain ist oder so, wo dann filtern wir das, ne, woraufhin dann wenn Netzpolitik ORG sagte, ja, wir haben aber hier eine orgdoman, was machen was bedeutet das? Ähm.
Und er hat ja jetzt also auch mal sehr äh sehr ernüchternde äh Stellung zugenommen und hat gesagt, äh die funktionieren im Prinzip gar nicht. Ähm da wird noch nicht mal die Sprache geprüft. Ja, also,
deutscher Kommunikationsinhalt wäre ja wahrscheinlich sogar der beste äh der beste,
den du auf großer äh Basis anwenden könntest, um zu sagen, wir filtern deutsche Kommunikation aus, ne? Ähm,
das wäre natürlich ein absolut fehlerhafter Filter, ja und sie alle sind das. Ja, du kannst eben nicht äh das tun,
Und genau das war ja auch allen immer klar. Nur KM hat das jetzt auch einfach mal gesagt, so ja nö, dat äh die sind im Prinzip darauf ausgelegt, nicht zu funktionieren diese Filter. Also hat jetzt nicht wörtlich gesagt, aber so ungefähr kann man ihn äh verstehen.
Und äh sagt er, natürlich funktionieren die alle nicht, ja klar. So, also wie gesagt, er hat entweder das Memo nicht bekommen oder äh sollte durchaus mal als äh.
Der kriegt jetzt noch ein Memo.
Sicherlich noch ein Memo. Ich glaube auch nicht, dass wir den nochmal sehen werden, im Endeffekt Untersuchungsausschuss. Ähm aber das war auf jeden Fall mal bemerkenswert, dass da jemand ähm.
Mal so äh klar da äh ausgesagt hat, weil er natürlich damit auch äh vorherige Aussagen von anderen BND-Mitarbeitern, die äh äh eben das Lügen straft, ja? Insofern äh dürfen wir gespannt sein, wie es da weitergeht.
Gut, kommen wir zu äh weiteren Enthüllungen der letzten Zeit. Das ist schon ein paar Tage her eigentlich, ne?
Ja, das ist schon, das ist schon älter. Ähm wir haben darüber berichtet in Folge einhundertfünf,
über äh die strategische Initiative Technik ähm,
quasi ein Plan des BND über sechs Jahre, äh dreihundert äh Millionen Euro auszugeben für hauptsächlich äh Technik. Und zwar wollen die,
Zweitausendvierzehn wurde erst vorbereitet. Zweitausendfünfzehn,
geht's dann los mit der Umsetzung der verschiedenen Maßnahmen, Pakete, um dann zweitausendzwanzig diese Initiative abgeschlossen zu haben,
Das wurde äh relativ ausführlich vor, wie gesagt, wann war das eben vor von neunundvierzig Folgen äh veröffentlicht beizeit online,
Zeit online hat aber damals nicht das Originaldokument oder die Originaldokumente veröffentlicht und das wurde jetzt von Andre bei Netzpolitik org nachgeholt.
Im Prinzip sind das fünf.
Bereiche, in denen da die Wunschliste des BNDs sich erstreckt. Es ist einmal Signd, also Signals Intelligence, Aufklärung durch technische Signalerfassung. Äh
Da wollen sie also äh Meterdaten zentrierter arbeiten, also ähm,
zielgerichtet und in Echtzeit-Meterdaten erfassen, äh statt sich auf Inhalte zu konzentrieren.
Dann wollen sie Internetoperationsfähigkeiten aufbauen, ähm also,
mehr technische Möglichkeiten zur Erkundung des Internets haben ähm,
ähm um eben gegen Deutschland gerichtete Comic Kommunikationen und Inhalte aufzuspüren, dann haben sie ein Paket sensorik,
ähm.
Um besser sich im Bereich atomarer biologischer und chemischer Waffen äh informieren zu können. Ähm das war, glaube ich, ein Teil, den äh bei der bei der Veröffentlichung Zeit online nicht dabei war aus,
vielleicht nachvollziehbaren Gründen, dass sie gesagt haben, okay, die äh Maßnahmen, Pakete oder die die äh der Stand des BND.
Zum heutigen Zeitpunkt lässt sich ja aus dieser Veröffentlichung herauslesen. Da steht ja drin, wir wollen als nächstes das hier kaufen und du kannst ja das Engagement in diesen unterschiedlichen Bereichen ähm.
Quasi in so einer Art Reifegraden sehen. Wenn du siehst, okay, die wollen sich jetzt dieses und jenes kaufen, dann kannst du ungefähr,
Daraus abschätzen, wo sie im Moment sehen, sind.
Ähm deswegen sind einige Teile davon damals nicht veröffentlicht worden. Äh dann wollen sie sich äh der Biometrie widmen, da wollen sie also ähm
Maßnahmen der Biometrieverzerrung
prüfen, weil sie eben merken, okay, wenn wir irgendwie Geheimagenten irgendwo einschleusen und so, ne, und deren Gesichter vielleicht in in Biometrieerfassungssystemen äh sind, dann dann müssen wir dagegen irgendwas tun.
Und außerdem wollen und dann wollen sie abschließend noch die integrierte Datenanalyse ähm einführen. Äh nennen sie AIDA, Ausbau der integrierten Datenanalyse. Ähm.
Wo sie also die Datenbestände ähm zusammenführen und darin zusammenhänge äh erkennen wollen. Ja?
Das sind also die, die fünf Bereiche, in denen sie äh über sieben Jahre jeweils irgendwie ungefähr dreiundvierzig Millionen Euro abgeben wollen.
Ähm,
Andre hat das hier sehr schön nochmal in Zusammenhang gesetzt. Äh im Jahreshaushalt zweitausendfünfzehn erhält der BND sechshundertfünfzehn Millionen Euro Zuschuss, ja? Und da wollen sie also jetzt dreihundert Millionen über sechs Jahre haben.
Na ja und dann hat äh gibt's da äh in der Veröffentlichung also einmal die äh die original Texte, was sie wie vorhaben, was sie da im Detail kaufen wollen. Ähm,
Und wie viel Geld sie da ausgeben wollen. Kann man sich an der Stelle mal anschauen.
Ja, damit ist der eigentliche Nachrichtenblock erst mal durch, oder?
Ja, wir haben noch einen, wir haben noch ein, ein Projekt zu äh vorzustellen oder zu bewerben.
Und zwar äh im Geiste verschiedener äh Exite. Man kennt das so aus dem Nazibereich vor allem den Begriff, oder? Weiß nicht, ob ich's schon mal woanders so gehört habe.
Also Geheimdienste bieten äh bieten Aussteigerprogramme an.
Geheimdienste bieten Aussteiger brauchen wir? Ach so, für, ach so, ja, wenn man.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das nur von Geheimdienst, also Aussteigerprogramme gibt's ja für alles, aber wenn du jetzt irgendwie äh äh wenn du jetzt irgendwie äh bei bei den beim IS gelandet bist oder so oder bei den Nazis, dann dann gibt es gibt es Hilfe,
Es gibt Hilfe und das sind Aussteigerprogramme, die von unterschiedlichen äh NGOs oder ich glaube auch von staatlichen Institutionen angeboten werden,
um dir den Ausstieg zu ermöglichen. Ja und ich glaube es, ich.
Es gibt halt explizit exit Deutschland darauf bezog ich mich jetzt sozusagen ja also ein,
Kein Geheimdienstprojekt, sondern eben explizit eine Hilfsorganisation um um Nazis den Ausstieg aus der Szene zu ermöglichen, was ja schwierig genug ist und ich denke, dass es so ein bisschen die Anleihe, die er an dieser Stelle genommen wird für das Projekt Intel Exit.
Dass ich jetzt gerade ähm mit all ja ziemlichen,
breit aufgestellt äh dem Netz entgegen. Ähm äh stellt und dort halt mit einem fetten Video äh dafür wirbt, dass
Geheimdienstmitarbeiter doch mal an ihre Gewissen äh appellieren sollen und überlegen sollen, ob sie nicht vielleicht sich aus diesem Ganzen,
komplex befreien, wie Herr Snowden das getan hat und äh einige andere auch.
Tja, ich weiß nicht, ist noch alles sehr frisch. Ähm wird debattiert, hat auch so ein bisschen für äh Verwirrung äh gesorgt, weil, glaube ich, nicht allen erst mal ganz klar war, wer so dahintersteckt.
Aber es ist jetzt ernst gemeint.
Also das Problem ist ja durchaus äh vorhanden. Du hast wenn du.
Dir anschaust, was mit ähm,
Geheimdienst Whistle Blauern, den Bekannten äh passiert ist, dann funktioniert natürlich diese Drohgebärde, die an diesen Exempeln eben auch stattuiert wird, ne.
Und ähm,
Entsprechend ist es natürlich durchaus keine äh oder durchaus eine wichtige und gute Idee zu sagen, hier wir haben ein Aussteigerprogramm. Wenn du diesen Schritt gehst, bist du nicht allein. Hier sind Leute,
Die beraten dich von Anfang an, die haben Ressourcen um dich zu schützen und ähm.
Die helfen dir dabei, deinen Ausstieg äh äh vorzunehmen. Nicht unbedingt überhaupt zum zu werden, sondern vielleicht auch einfach
kündigen, ja?
Kann ja äh kann ja auch sein. Insofern haben sie bieten sie ja auch direkt diesen äh Rasic Nation Letter an, ja? Also kannst du klickst du dich irgendwie durch und dann kriegst du einen äh vorgedruckten äh
Kündigungsschreiben, ja? Kannst also auf Exit Now drücken und dann äh sagst du irgendwie klickst du so ein paar Gründe an, dann fällt dir ein fällt da am Ende ein PDF raus. Das kannst du dann dahin
schicken. Außerdem geben Sie sechs Gründe, ja? Also
dass du selber überwacht wirst, wie es deiner Familie geht, was du hier wie Frieden und wie Freiheit und Demokratie zu schützen sind und so weiter. Ne, da,
Ähm geben sie dir also unter äh Stützung und sagen auch okay, es ist völlig egal. Du kannst leise gehen
ja oder als Whistleblower gehen, äh in beiden Fällen äh unterstützen wir dich, ne? Du kommst äh,
kommst, wir wir bringen dich in Kontakt mit Organisationen, die dafür gedacht sind, dich in in beiden Situationen zu schützen.
Und ähm da äh bietet bietet diese Gruppe eben Hilfe an.
Haben auch natürlich das Ganze jetzt mit relativ viel äh medialem,
äh Interesse gelauncht und fahren jetzt irgendwie glaube ich dann mit so mit so Werbeautos irgendwie äh bei GCHQ und NSA vor der Tür rum,
Plakate hingeklebt und so ähm.
Finde ich äh ganz wichtig, den Menschen dem auch zu zeigen, so nee, bist du, da bist du nicht alleine, die äh Zivilgesellschaft äh fängt dich auf.
Das Ganze ist ja jetzt ein Projekt von äh Peng, Berlin.
Gruppe, die äh auch schon mal erwähnt wurde, glaube ich und ähm bisher.
Auch so ein bisschen so in diesem Guerilla-Style, Medienöffentlichkeits äh Ding verortet werden musste, so. Die coole Aktion gemacht haben.
Ich weiß nicht so ganz genau, ob das jetzt zu dem Auftreten von Intel Exit als seriöses Projekt so ohne weiteres äh,
zusammenpasst. Also bei mir hat das erstmal so ein bisschen Verwirrung ausgelöst, ob sich nicht hierbei dann äh nur um eine große Kunstaktion handelt.
Also Peng hat äh und äh kennt vielleicht, kennt vielleicht nicht alle Hörenden. Äh Peng hat
zum Beispiel auf der Republik hat er diese neuen Google Produkte mal vorgestellt, die es nicht gab, äh für Vattenfall irgendwie
die Fortführung von bestimmten äh Projekten oder die Abschaffung von Braunkohletagebau und so was bekannt gegeben. Ähm.
Großartiger Auftritt bei Astro TV.
Genau, bei Astro TV, das hatten wir auch hier besprochen, ähm
So, haben also mit dem mit dem Clown, der der sich da gemeldet hat, haben wir also äh viele so Mediengeriler Sachen gemacht. Und ähm waren jetzt,
haben vielleicht bis jetzt nicht ihr Profil geprägt als äh vertrauensvolle Stelle, der ich mich mit etwas anvertraue, was äh möglicherweise mein Leben gefährden kann.
Das ist, glaube ich, dein dein Punkt, ne. In dem in dem Video und das deswegen haben sie sich, glaube ich, auch hier
mit vielen anderen zusammen getan, dass nämlich nicht nur eine Aktion von Peng, sondern sie haben hier im Video tritt dann Bruce Schneider auf und äh Thomas ist ja NSA Whistleblower, ähm der da dieses, der sich da diesem Projekt ähm.
Anschließt und dafür wirbt, äh sie haben,
mit an Bord. Sie werben hier auch für die Foundation. Also sie haben da durchaus ein
ein breites Bündnis aufgebaut, aber den äh den Punkt, den du da glaube ich gerade benennst, das ist äh jetzt irgendwie
als Peng-Aktion, also Peng ist in dem Rahmen jetzt wahrscheinlich kein Name, der äh Vertrauen schafft, deswegen steht er auch relativ klein da unten. Aber es ist nun mal eine Aktion, äh die von Peng,
ähm auf die Beine gestellt wurde.
Und sind denn die anderen, die da jetzt da auch als Referenz genannt werden, dass man sich dort informieren kann, wie es da so schön heißt, äh wie Corridge Foundation et cetera äh sind die denn jetzt wirklich auch Teil dieses Projektes oder nicht?
Ich.
Äh gehe davon aus, dass sie äh also ähm wie das Projekt jetzt genau auf den Beinen steht,
ähm kann ich nicht sagen und ich glaube, ehrlich gesagt, dass es da jetzt auch gar nicht so viel ähm.
Strukturelle Basis gibt,
Dass da jetzt eine riesige Organisation hinter ist, die äh Prozesse und Abläufe hat und und Geschäftsführer oder so, ja, sondern dass es ähm,
dass es hier darum geht, so wir haben eine Möglichkeit, da kannst du dich hinwenden und da sind Leute, die sorgen dafür, dass,
An den Ansprechpartner gerätst, der dir mit deinen Schwierigkeiten weiterhelfen kann.
Denke, dass es äh das das Entscheidende hier weniger als das jetzt äh da äh klar schon steht, wer alles äh wer alles was macht.
Okay, also an sich eine unterstützenswerte Initiative äh jetzt noch ein bisschen, ich denke, er ist noch ein bisschen Nacharbeit äh erforderlich, um einfach da die Verwirrung äh zu verhindern.
Um wirklich klar zu machen, wie das äh wie das Projekt aufgestellt ist. Und ähm ja, dann schauen wir mal, wie sich das entwickelt.
Äh also wie gesagt, ich glaube, da sind genug Namen bei, die äh die dem Projekt äh.
Verleihen.
Leum und verleihen, ja? Also irgendwie Jeremys äh Zimmermann von Lack vor der Tür, Dunette äh ist, glaube ich, ein klarer
Kandidat hier, aber es gibt eben auch diese künstlerische Komponente da drin, die,
Ja, wie du sagst, vielleicht nicht unbedingt das Vertrauen in dieses äh Projekt äh.
Noch mehr stärkt, als es die anderen prominenten Namen, die da jetzt mit in Verbindung gebracht werden, tun.
Gut, damit kommen wir zum Ende. Äh unserer Sendung. Sind auch ein paar Danksagungen im Gepäck.
Habe ich. Ähm und zwar an äh Ben und Christian äh gilt. Ben und Christian gilt diese Woche, der herzliche Dank,
für das Ermöglichen dieser Sendung. Haben wir, aber haben wir noch andere abschließende Worte. Das ist jetzt, du gehst jetzt zu schnell, hier zum zum Ende. Das äh ach so, ja, schon wieder eine Stunde. Ähm wollen wir noch irgendwas sagen?
Weiß ich nicht, irgendwas anderes. Volkswagen willst du ja nichts zu sagen. Ich auch nicht.
Was soll man dazu noch sagen.
Was sie dazu noch sagen.
Wäre sicherlich irgendwie nochmal eine interessante äh Diskussion unter so Security-Aspekten äh ähm Security auf der einen Seite, aber eben auch so,
Trust in Systems. Ähm auch wenn ich da jetzt kein unmittelbaren nutzpolitischen Faden jetzt gerade aufnehmen kann in der Hinsicht, von daher äh sollte man dann vielleicht nochmal ein bisschen drüber nachdenken und vor allem mal rauskriegen, was halt wirklich passiert ist.
Also klar ist, da ist was passiert so, ne, aber äh die Details fände ich äh an der Stelle schon sehr interessant und ich denke auch, dass dieser ganze Kram nicht bei Volkswagen verbleiben wird, da werden wir sicherlich noch einiges mehr hören,
Oh, ich habe mich da jetzt, ehrlich gesagt, noch zu keinem wirklichen Statement äh hingearbeitet.
Ja, also die netzpolitische, das Netzpolitische Ausmaß dieses Problems äh hält sich in Grenzen. Aber äh ich suche das jetzt gerade verzweifelt ähm.
Es gibt eine netzpolitische Komponente, auf die nämlich auch die Electronic Foundation aufmerksam macht, allerdings in den USA. Äh da sie nämlich sagen,
Der DMCA Digital Millennium Copyright Act. Ähm.
Verhindert im Prinzip, dass Forscher ähm.
Sachen sich genauer anschauen und sagen, wenn es da eine Softwaremanipulation gibt.
Ähm oder unter dem Digital Millennium Copyweat Account Hersteller derartige Sachen besser verstecken.
Sagen, dass äh wenn die Rechtslage besser wäre, ähm für unabhängige Forscher.
Dann wäre es vielleicht viel früher herausgekommen, ja? Sagen also, wenn wir unser,
Unsere Gesundheit, unsere Sicherheit und unsere Privatsphäre einem Gerät anvertrauen, dann sollte das Gesetz nicht jene Strafen, die versuchen,
zu verstehen, wie dieses Gerät funktioniert und ob man ihm vertrauen kann.
Und äh insofern sagen sie ähm dass es dass sie hoffen, dass es da jetzt äh Ausnahmen geben wird, dass sie nämlich sehr wohl als unabhängiger Forscher ohne rechtliche Grauzone äh derartige Forschung unternehmen kannst.
Ja guter Punkt, ich meine das wirkt mindestens äh etwas abschreckend. Magst nicht vielleicht komplett verhindern, weil wir sehen ja auch, dass sich genug äh Security Forscher durchaus grade auch auf die Automobilindustrie äh stürzen.
Äh ich weiß gar nicht, ob wir darüber gesprochen haben, aber es gab ja jetzt diese ganzen Fälle mit äh gehackte Teslas et cetera
eigentlich so eher so typische Security Dinger, mit denen man mehr oder weniger auch rechnet, wenn man sich so ein bisschen in dieser Welt aufhält.
Aber daraus äh lässt sich sehr wohl eine gesamtgesellschaftliche äh Debatte ableiten, insbesondere im Hinblick auf die ganzen Fragestellungen, die jetzt kommen mit autonomen Fahren. Auch wenn sie jetzt natürlich hier erstmal um die reine äh,
Regelgesetzgebung rund um Zulassung äh geht und einfach den Beschiss das einfach Verbrennungsmotoren wahrscheinlich nochmal viel äh problematischer sind, als sie äh als sie offiziell gelten,
Ja. Ich persönlich, ehrlich gesagt,
hoffe, dass dass das jetzt irgendwie der, der erste äh vielleicht noch nicht der finale Todesstoß war, aber auf jeden Fall schon mal der Anstoß,
zum Ende des Verbrennungsmotors.
Ja, ich auch, weil ähm
Ich habe mir auch vorgenommen, also der der Tod ist Verbrennungsmotors muss jetzt schnell eintreten, weil vielleicht brauche ich ja doch noch mal irgendwann ein Auto und ich habe nämlich mir vorgenommen, dass ich keine Autos mehr kaufen werde, die.
Dinosaurier verbrennen.
Den Sauer verbrennen und deshalb äh müssen jetzt relativ schnell die E-Autos äh erschwinglich werden. Wobei ich vielleicht wahrscheinlich sowieso nie wieder ein Auto kaufen werde. Ich halte das für Unsinn. Autonomes Auto, kann ich auch mieten, brauche ich nicht zu kaufen.
Ist schon mal ein elektrisches Auto gefahren.
Achso, ja, ja, ja, diese,
und so, nee, brauche ich nicht.
Es lockt auf jeden Fall sehr.
Ja, also da da können wir dann nochmal drüber reden, ob das jetzt selbst fährt oder oder ob ich da noch irgendwie manu manueller Tätigkeit äh mich herablassen muss. Äh aber der Antrieb sollte auf jeden Fall äh elektrisch funktionieren.
Genauso.
Gut.
Gut. Mit diesem Unausgegorenen äh Abschluss hinterlassen wir euch. In fortwährende Unklarheit und äh bedanken uns fürs Zuhören.
Bis bald.